what would my graphics this video is
made possible by the good people at
skill share helping people level up
their skills since 2010 if you haven't
joined yet what have you been doing for
the last nine years wasting your time
being unskilled that's what drawing
skill share today through the link below
and support our show and yourself by
getting more mad skills and let's get
into it three centuries after the fall
of the Roman Empire most of Western
Europe was divided into small kingdoms
frequently at war with each other they
were threatened by the Umayyad Caliphate
from the south subject to the influence
of the Byzantine Empire from the east
and prone to the interference of the
papacy cultural and economic development
languished marred by a lack of strategic
vision and the loss of centuries worth
of classical knowledge then in the
eighth century a new ruler emerged a
king who would bring about a cultural
political and military renaissance he
could be as ruthless with his enemies as
he was enlightened in his administration
of his kingdom
today's protagonist was hailed as the
father of modern Europe he was
celebrated in arts in literature and
even in heavy-metal concept albums sung
by Christopher leap his name was Charles
the great better known as Charmaine
[Music]
Matra Charlene's life is documented by a
biography and hard who was his
contemporary and he also happened to be
his maths teacher when the King was
already in adults however Einhard
himself admits that little is known
about his early years we do know that
the boy Charles later known as Charmaine
was probably born in arkin modern-day
Germany in 742 he was the eldest son of
King Pepin of the Franks and had a
brother called Carla Mott Carla man
means free man man King Pepin was the
first of a new dynasty the Carolinians
named after his own father Charles
Martel Charles Martel was not a king
though he was a mayor of the palace to
the kings of the Merovingian dynasty
which had ruled the region since the
Year 450 the Merovingians had been
losing power and influence for years
becoming merely figureheads while the
real power was wielded by the mayor a
role sort of like today's prime minister
Pepin was
Ben's on replacing the last of the
Merovingians childerik the third as
monarch and sole ruler to do so he
needed legitimacy and at that time the
finest purveyor of legitimacy was the
Pope he addressed a letter to Pope
Zachary in Rome asking is it right that
a powerless ruler should continue to
bear the title of king Zachary agreed
immediately he needed a powerful
champion as the church in Rome was under
a double threat politically the lombard
kingdom in italy was increasingly
hostile towards the pope secular rule
ideologically the Byzantine Empire
wanted to impose a ban on
representations of Christ in all Western
European churches as this was seen as
idolatry Pepin was crowned king of the
Franks in 751 and named both of his sons
as successors he defeated the Lombards
donating a large portion of their land
to Zachary the Pope in return
thanks Bevin by graciously and totally
scanning him let me explain Zachary
produced a document known as the
donation of Constantine drafted by the
Roman Emperor himself which stated that
all Christian monarchs gave up their
rule voluntarily to the papacy and that
the Pope then handed it back in other
words a king was such by the grace of
the Pope and the Pope had the ultimate
authority over his right to reign Pepin
accepted this but what he did not know
being poorly educated and illiterate is
that the document was a forgery and
instruments by which the papacy sought
to control Christian kingdoms while his
father ascended to the throne and dealt
with popes in lombards we can assume
that Charles was busy training to become
the warrior king that he would later
become we already going to relate to
specific episodes of his youth in two
occasions at the age of six and then at
the age of 15 he swore an oath of
allegiance to the papacy and Christendom
Charles was uses sword to protect and
expand Christianity an oath that would
shape many of his military decisions in
768 Heaven died and the Frankish Kingdom
was split among his two sons at this
time the kingdom included most of
modern-day France Belgium and some
territories in western Germany Charles
and Karl Amon did not get along very
well due to their radically different
personalities Charles always favored
direct action while his brother was less
impulsive
the first major disagreement came when
the province of Akutan in southwestern
France rebelled in 769 carlomon was
against military intervention while
Charles could not wait to march against
the rebels
which he did quickly defeating them and
annexing a new province Gascony along
the way the following year 770 Charles
is 28 and he thought it was time to
marry his was a political choice a
lombard princess daughter of King
Desiderius the marriage was so unhappy
and short-lived that we don't even know
the name of the girl Charles in fact
repudiated her the same year to marry a
Swabian teenager Hildegard Desiderius
was furious he approached carlomon
proposing an alliance to topple that
playboy Charles and a civil war was on
the horizon the very conveniently
carlomon died in 771 apparently of
natural causes the Frankish Kingdom
there was now united under Shara's rule
for most of the time of his 56 year
reign Charles was busy with military
campaigns crushing rebellions securing
borders and expanding his dominions
according to historian CW Hollister
these campaigns initially we're not born
out of a clear vision
Charles led his armies on yearly
campaigns as a matter of course only
gradually did he develop a notion of
Christian mission and a program of
unifying and systematically expanding
the Christian West
so we'll first take a look at his wars
against the Saxons which he waged from
772 to 804 nowadays Saxony corresponds
to a vast area of northern Germany
bordering the Netherlands and Denmark
the Saxon people were split into several
different tribes and had been on good
terms with the Franks which used their
territory as a trade route with the
Danes
things changed in 772 when a Saxon party
raided and burned a church in the
Frankish town of Devon - it is not known
why but this was the perfect excuse for
Schultz to invade the Saxons still held
pagan beliefs and worships the Norse
pantheon of gods something Charles did
not tolerate it has been speculated that
the de vente raid may have been a false
flag attack orchestrated by the Franks
in retaliation Charles led his army into
Saxony and destroyed the sacred tree
mince all the Tree of Life in Norse
mythology this was only the first of 18
invasions all marked by much burning
pillaging and slaughtering in 777 the
Saxon tribes united behind the warrior
chief Whittington's a name which
translates as child of the forest his
resistance was brave and hard force but
he had little
chance to succeed against the Frankish
Army's wooden kins did succeed in
convincing King secret of Denmark to
allow Saxon refugees into his kingdom
though Charles is campaigning it grew
increasingly ruthless perpetrating
actions that nowadays would have have
him trialed at the hague International
Court of Justice in 782 he ordered the
murder of 4,500 Saxon prisoners this was
the massacre of Verdun an atrocity
condemned even by his contemporaries the
Saxons continued fighting preserving
their autonomy and their religion but
Vidin kind realized that this could not
go on forever and he allowed himself to
be baptized in 785 as a gesture of peace
the rebel leader disappeared from
historical records after this events but
his followers they still did not yield
shells continued with his campaigns even
preventing refugees from escaping to
Denmark in 798 after 32 years of war
Charles had finally found a solution in
804 he ordered the mass deportation of
10,000 Saxons to new stria northwestern
France while locating a similar number
of Franks into Saxony this forced
displacement effectively ended the
conflict and absorbed Saxony into
Charles's dominions nationalist
territories they bordered with Denmark
and this did not please the Scandinavian
Kings secret of Denmark attacked freesia
today's Netherlands almost immediately
fortunately for the Friesians the Dane
died shortly afterwards and his
successor sued for peace while waging a
protracted conflict against the Saxons
Charles was able to conduct campaigns in
other parts of Europe in 774 answering a
plea from the Pope II crossed the Alps
and defeated the lombards after
perceiving their capital / via the
lombard kingdom was annexed by Charles
who now became king of the Franks and
the lombards he then turned his
attention to the Basques who were
threatening Gascony the Basques were and
are a tough bunch and defeated Charles
at the Battle of Ronceverte pass in 778
but ultimately they were beaten as where
the Saracens in northern Spain the
Franks in the Saracens or Moors
continued fighting intermittently until
Charles was able to seize from the Moors
Corsica Sardinia and the Balearic
Islands in northern Spain the Saracens
were put in check by the foundation of
the Spanish March fortified buffer zone
extending from the Pyrenees to the Ebro
River and Barcelona during the seven 80s
Showell scored further Victor
in Romania and Italy he expanded his
kingdom southwards in 787 by conquering
part of southern Italy after the siege
of Solano he also stretched eastward by
annexing Bavaria and Carinthia
modern-day Austria in 788 in 795 Charles
attacked the powerful Empire of the
avars of Hungary
he had his sights set on them since the
conquest of Lombardy but had interrupted
the campaign to deal with the Saxons in
the meantime the Civil War had weakens
the air boss Charles took advantage and
by 796 he had conquered their fortified
capital known as the ring looting their
enormous treasure after a revolt in 799
the 'var were definitively crushed in
803 further expansion continued in
Eastern Europe the northern Balkans and
the lands of the rivers of oder and the
Danube all became dependent territories
of the mighty charmaine now you might
not be mighty right now but that's only
because you haven't become extremely
skilled through the use of skill share
today's sponsor skill share of 30000
courses covering everything from basic
battlefield tactics to how to manage a
raiding party and even the skills needed
for effective pillaging not really
obviously but really skill share has
legit stuff I mean I'm sure we'd all
love to go out raiding but hey we
probably should be focusing on practical
skills like productivity
programming and presentation skills and
guys that's just the piece I could go on
those are the things we need in life and
many more things which are all available
to learn on Skillshare and it's all
super affordable look I'm the sort of
person who will go to that
all-you-can-eat sushi place and
absolutely gorgeous to she and that's
why I like skill share stick with me
here I'm like at the platform skill
share is just one affordable monthly fee
and you can take all the courses you
want it's like all-you-can-eat sushi
except for knowledge and skills you
don't have to pay for individual courses
at all and guess what guys we've got an
ultra ultra exclusive deal two months
free you've never heard that anywhere
else before the seriously though if you
do sign up through our link below you do
get two months for free and it would
make a big difference if you use my link
because then it supports this show I
would love you for that
and let's get back to Charlie
all the kingdoms of populations seemed
to succumb incredibly easy to Charles
his armies except for the Saxons so how
did Charles achieve this what were his
winning strategies the Frankish army it
was organized around a corps of heavy
cavalry an aristocratic warrior elite
wearing chainmail and rounded helmets
armed with swords and Lance's they were
supported by infantry carrying pole arms
and shields fighting in massed ranks
disappointingly value-add Charmaine's
armies avoided large pitch battles if
possible surprisingly when they were
lured into battle they performed poorly
the Frankish established their
superiority through well-prepared
long-term campaigns instead which
harassed and wore down their opponents
over time
in fact the value of Charles's cavalry
did not lay in spectacular charges
against enemy fortifications rather
Charles exploited its speed of
deployments the ability to harass
enemies burned villages loot and pillage
before quickly moving on to another
theater Charles is also a master of
logistics he usually planned his
campaigns around Easter the period in
which plenty of fodder was available for
the horses making the most of the Army's
greatest asset his vassals were ordered
to gather at least three months worth of
food prior to a campaign to ensure
sustainability
unlike the custom at the time the
Frankish army did not simply raid enemy
territories and then leave as a means to
enrich themselves
Charles made sure that new fortresses
were built and Garrison's in the areas
he invaded another acid at Charles's
disposal was the sheer size of his army
numbering up to 35,000 men while
relatively small numbers for late
Classical period standards this was a
juggernaut compared to the enemies of
the Franks this allows Charles to split
up his army into two or more cause and
to perform pincer movements to
outmaneuver their defenses in short
Charmaine's dominance in logistics and
strategy meant that he could afford to
avoid the battlefields but if he did
engage in battle and lost well he could
still win the war what really made
possible this military organization was
the administrative reforms which Charles
implemented during his reign
[Music]
in order to administer such a large
territory
Charles divided his kingdom into an
inner core and an outer regna the core
comprised the provinces of Austrasia
nise trya and burgundy supervised
directly by him and a system of envoy's
the outer regner was divided into
counties each ruled by a trusted count
or Earl in turn they presided over a
number of layers of each of
whom was expected to train and equip
himself for cavalry warfare
the counts could also rely on seven
scappini each these were experts in law
which ensured unity in the
administration of justice border
counties were grouped into marches and
they were ruled by Marcus's they have
the responsibility to maintain border
line fortifications and raise Rapid
Reaction forces in case of an invasion
large territory is characterized by a
distinctive ethnic group were organized
as duchies Charles also created two sub
kingdoms in Aquitaine and Italy ruled by
his sons Louis and Pepin respectively
all the local rulers were summons to
attend an annual assembly the march
field in which they discussed political
judicial military and religious matters
Charles's success as a ruler can be
traced to his admiration for learning
and education his reign assured in the
Carolingian Renaissance characterized by
a rebirth of scholarship literature art
and architecture Charmaine's conquests
they brought him into contact with the
cultures of Moorish Spain anglo-saxon
England and Lombard Italy which greatly
increased the institution of monastic
schools and copying centers charmaine
took a serious interest in scholarship
promoting the liberal arts at the course
ordering that his children and
grandchildren be well educated and even
studying himself he studied grammar
rhetoric logic astronomy and arithmetic
surprisingly he was not able to write
and even his ability to read has been
put into question by historians what is
not in question though was the fact that
Charles had created the single largest
political entity in Western Europe since
the fall of the Roman Empire in 476 his
kingdom had unified wildly different
territories and ethnicities they had
been unified by force but they were kept
together by his administrative skills
which included the creation of a single
currency and even a single writing
system the Carolingian minuscule which
established unified rules for language
script and grammar to ensure effective
can
occasion among every corner of the
kingdom and this kingdom well it was
about to formally become an empire in
the year 800 Pope Leo the third fell
victim to a conspiracy led by Roman
Nobles accused of immorality and abuse
of his office he was forced to flee Leo
approached Charles asking for help to
regain the seat of Peter Charles
consulted with his advisor who
recommended that he accepted the Pope's
plea for help in December of the same
year shells traveled to Rome to preside
over Leo's trial under his forceful
influence Leo's name was cleared on the
23rd of that month on Christmas Day the
pious Charles meant to pray in front of
some Peters tune when he emerged from
the crypts he was the target of a weird
ambush Leo the third just stepped in
front of him and placed over Charles's
head the imperial crown this was a crown
that had been headless in the West for
centuries with that simple gesture
charmaine had become the Holy Roman
Emperor in practical terms this did not
change anything with respect to its
territorial two minions allegedly
charmaine having been given the choice
would have refused the crown but still
he did accept the added prestige as a
clever man he had understood that the
coronation was a ruse concocted by Leo
to regain some authority after his
double humiliation first being ousted by
the Romans then begging Charles for help
Leo was basically saying I'm still
enough of a pope to make this man an
emperor but Charles was no fool and he
knew very well that the next step would
be for Leo to pull out of the donation
of Constantine if you remember this was
the forgery that had fooled his dad
Pepin charmaine did not fall for it and
never accepted the papacy as political
interference over his rule
when dealing with the life of such a
huge public figure it's easy to forget
the private man behind the scepter
thankfully Charmaine's biographer
Einhard left an account of his private
life Charles was a tall and powerful man
standing at six for three although he
had a short neck and a potbelly he
regularly ate five meals a day mainly
consisting of grilled or roast meat
apparently he disliked doctors after
they recommended that he switched to a
lighter diet of stews now already
mentions the first two wives the unnamed
lombard princess and Hildegard this
Swabian lady was always by a side even
during his campaigns and bore him four
sons and five daughters before dying at
the age of only 26 let's do some maths
yeah although very testing a healthy
woman could give birth to a child every
12 months of cart had nine children
assuming that she was constantly
pregnant they married when she was
fifteen if however she did have some
respite between pregnancies well that
would place her first pregnancy at an
even younger age but you know different
times different habits Hildegard was
buried in the Mets Cathedral and her
life became almost immediate fodder for
legends in which she was Rica sand blue
or white flower
shortly after Hildegard's death sholls
married first radha the daughter of an
Austrian count according to an heart she
was beautiful ambitious and cruel first
radha died in 794 and Charmaine married
a fourth time with lute guard I not
described her as ailing good and devout
lute guard barely managed to be emperors
she died in the year 800 after her
Charles did not marry again but he did
have four mistresses with whom he sired
five more children
unlike many monarchs before and after
him Charles had a very close bond with
his children spending plenty of time
with them and taking a personal interest
in their education he made sure they
studied to a proficient level the
subjects of grammar rhetoric dialectics
geometry astronomy and music after
reaching the appropriate age the sons
were taught the real manly staff
expected of medieval princes hunting
horse riding and weapons training but
how about the daughters well they were
taught will spinning nothing wrong with
this if it's your calling but maybe
they'd rather be off with that brothers
horse riding in the woods and chasing
wild animals Charles never allowed his
daughters to marry and this was probably
for political reasons he already had to
split his territory
among four sons and he could not afford
to do the same for his potential
sons-in-law
[Music]
in the later years of his life from 801
to 810 Charles faced arguably his most
powerful foe the Byzantine Empire
charmaine and Emperor nice efforts the
first waged war on land and sea for
control of Venetia and the donation'
coast the war progressed well for the
franks further in 809 nice aris was
distracted by a new war with boggers the
Byzantines began negotiations with the
Franks and peace was agreed upon in
which Charlemagne gave up most of the
Dalmatian coast in exchange for the
Byzantine Emperor recognizing him as
Emperor of the West in 813 charmaine
appointed his son Louis the pious as
successor to the Holy Roman Emperor
Tremaine died in 814 at the age of 72 of
natural causes unfortunately as death
marks the beginning of the ends for the
Empire and the ruling system that he had
created as pointed out by historian
professor cancer this was one of the
cases in which a single death of a
single person caused society around the
world to revert to a less developed
state charmaine have created a solid
infrastructure to ensure at least in
theory the survival of the Empire but he
had sowed the seeds of the decline with
his conduct in the Saxon Wars in
addition to perpetrating a series of
atrocities Charles's conduct had enraged
the Scandinavian Kings and eliminated
the Saxony buffer zone the danes waited
for Schultz's death and then unleash
their Viking raids on France which Louis
the pious was unable to effectively
fight back the deterioration was further
accelerated by the fact that the Empire
was later split amongst Louie's three
sons who had little interest in
cooperating and preserving Charles's
reforms these three and the descendants
were also under the influence and
interference of the papacy
unlike Charles they had bought into the
frauds that was the donation of
Constantine all in all Charles's
material legacy it did not last for more
than two generations however he said the
idea of the possibility of restoring a
strong unified Empire in Western Europe
he is also credited for being the
initiator of the concept of a united
Europe moreover the kingdoms he created
were the basis for current nation-states
and his cultural reforms slowly dragged
European people out of the Dark Ages so
I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe we've got brand new videos
just like this four times per week so
subscribe to this channel
so you can find out about those and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]